the 2022 juno awards took over toronto's
budweiser stage last night for an
unforgettable evening the weather was
perfect
i mean i think people were saying it was
a little hot but well yeah
and big wins include avril lavigne
delivering her medley of her biggest
hits shawn mendes accepting his
international achievement award and
there she is deborah cox making history
as the first black woman inducted into
the canadian music hall of fame i went
this weekend i went on a binge and
watched listen to all of her music
yeah that's right uh and proud canadian
similu did not disappoint as this year's
host uh he couldn't help but gush about
his hometown in his opening monologue
while delivering an emotional i'm
canadian speech and simu also caught up
with her very own morgan hoffman
backstage take a look and we'll see you
next time bye everyone i
love this country
and uh you know
i'm not a curler or anything but but i
know what it means to hurry hard
and the only fight i ever lost
was against the canada goose
i went to montreal for my 18th birthday
for the
wink wink
culture
and my favorite thing about toronto
the cn tower and drake
views
hashtag best i ever had
i proudly filled my days with canadian
inventions like basketball tim beams or
insulin and and hey not a lot of people
know this but canada also invented the
pacemaker which we all desperately need
because the leafs keep giving us heart
attacks
better luck next year
in
boys
you can truly have anything
except for affordable housing that one's
a tough one
because canada is a place where the
government is also our drug dealer and
we're into snowboarding
not waterboarding
and where a woman
always
has the right to choose
my name is simul liu
and i
am
canadian
you killed it do you feel good i feel
crazy i feel like my mind is on fire
like it's one of you know it's one of
the i don't i definitely have not come
down yet and so much canadian pride in
your speech yes
yes oh i'm i'm
i'm so glad that we got to do it and um
i think you know there were a lot of
important things that needed to be said
and i'm glad that we got the message out
there listen you were so smooth out
there but was anything going on
backstage that we didn't know about did
you fall did you slip wardrobe
malfunction something going on was
everything really that smooth did you
fall did you slip
that's my new rap that's the the um man
the thing that comes to mind is i just
as you can probably hear like my voice
is is kind of fried and so i think i was
just popping lozenges backstage and just
going and like guzzling
the hot tea which is never a good idea
trying to like save my voice